hi I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
welcome to science hangout today we have
a dr. Martin G Bala he's a professor and
a chair of the department of kinesiology
at McMaster University in Hamilton
Canada so he studies the beneficial
effects of exercise at the molecular to
whole body level in both healthy
individuals as well as people with
chronic diseases dr. de bellas research
on the physiological adaptations to
interval training has attracted immense
scientific attention worldwide and got
lots of media coverage he's the author
of the best-selling book on the topic
the 1 minute workout welcome dr. J Bala
to science hang out
thank you for having me on so let's talk
about yourself before we go into all
these exercise and let's talk about
yourself tell me about yourself your
background education how far you have
come
how is the journey beam yeah sure so
I've been a professor of McMaster for
about 20 years I my undergraduate
training was in a field called Human
Kinetics which goes by different names
including kinesiology which is the the
study of human movement as an
undergraduate I was interested in
physiology that was the the course that
in second year that really inspired my
attention and it taught about how the
body worked like a lot of people who
come into kinesiology I was interested
in exercise in different sports and so
physiology applied to the body allowed
me to think about my training in a
different way and and what physiological
systems were being stimulated and and so
that was my initial introduction to the
field and then I completed a master's
degree in kinesiology my PhD was in
human physiology and nutrition and then
I did a postdoctoral fellowship overseas
at the Copenhagen muscle research that
my interest in interval training has
really stemmed from two things both a
professional and a personal interest the
professional interest is for a long time
I've taught a course on the integrative
physiology of human performance and the
students are always interested in the
training regimes of elite athletes and I
would often ask them well why do these
elite endurance athletes triathletes and
cyclists why do they train using these
short hard bursts of exercise you know
some people call that an aerobic
training and why is that so effective
for their endurance performance and then
personally I was doing a lot of reading
around interval training starting out
you know I like a lot of people I was
very busy we had young children at the
time and so quite ironically for a
professor of exercise physiology I found
myself with little time to work out and
so I said well maybe I'll try this
interval training and so I I found that
it was something that allowed me to to
maintain my fitness despite a reduced
time commitment and so that was the the
personal interest okay
and let's talk about you a lab lab
people so just let us know about like
how it is like what is the lab size yes
we have a mix of individuals are always
a few undergraduate students that get
involved typically in in third year we
have a research practicum course that's
a a one semester course that allows
students to get some exposure to the lab
a couple of undergraduate thesis
students and then grad students
typically at any given time I will have
four or five usually roughly split
between master's students and and PhDs
I don't have any postdoctoral fellows
right now but I've had a postdoctoral
fellow in the past so typically the lab
size is eight to ten students and that's
a mix of junior undergraduates right up
to two senior PhD students and then here
McMaster we have a an integrative
physiology group that has five or six
members depending how you count and so
it's quite a stimulating environment
with the number of colleagues
study and in similar but different areas
and so collectively within our exercise
metabolism research group there's 75 or
80 people so it makes for a very I think
stimulating environment for trainees
okay and I know you had a busy person
with the books with the research and all
those things how do you spend you at a
time like you have some spare time how
do you spend it yeah sure so I have two
two children who are both active in in
in sports and so part of my time is
spent volunteering with them ice hockey
is their their main sport as well as one
plays baseball so I like to be involved
with their activities in a coaching or
assisting manner
obviously as someone who likes physical
activity I I try to prioritize my
exercise time and and and fit that in
into my day and then you know some
reading some other pursuits thing things
like that but that's what consumes most
of my time is either my work or or my
family okay and coming back to science
part of it you wrote a book recently on
one minute workout so like let's get
into a little bit more detail about what
is this one minute workout who invented
it how long it is been the tell tell us
about little bit more in detail because
people may not know about it some of the
people sure so you know my lab broad
least focuses on or has been interested
in studying the physiology of interval
exercise training and so sure many
people have heard of interval training
which is really just alternating periods
of more intense effort with recovery
within a single training session
athletes have used the technique
effectively for well over a hundred
years and even at the turn of the
century some high-profile athletes who
were winning Olympic gold medals and
World Championships in endurance type
sports or activities were nonetheless
using interval training as a way to to
help their performance and then over the
course of time interval training is it's
rediscovered if you will every few years
for every decade or so and so we get a
lot of credit for studying interval
training but it's really just versions
on a theme of what people have
previously been interested in over the
last 10 or 15 years though I think
there's been two main areas one has been
the application of interval training to
less trained individuals non healthy
individuals we've done studies for
example applying interval training to
people with type 2 diabetes my
colleagues have studied it in a
cardiovascular or cardiac rehab setting
so in people who have had a heart attack
or myocardial infarction looking at
recovery in the application of interval
training and those individuals so
definitely there's been an explosion of
research interest in the application of
interval exercise training to these
people who are are not young fit
athletes and secondly and where the
title of the book comes from we've been
interested in the question of how low
can you go or looking at really small
doses of interval exercise and showing
that you can have adaptations including
in health markers which we normally
associate with much more traditional
endurance exercise and so some of our
protocols has involved exercise as
little as 322nd bursts bigger it's
exercise that adds up to a minute and so
that was really the background for the
title of the book the 1 minute workout
okay so do you think this 1 minute
workout is good enough for somebody to
keep fake like what is your experiment
says yeah so let me answer that a couple
of ways so the short answer is yes you
can achieve improvements in many
different markers that are important for
health with these short vigorous
exercise bouts and in some of our
studies we've shown that for example
doing these three 20-second bursts of
activity you can have improvements in
health markers that are very similar to
what you would achieve with more
traditional moderate intensity
continuous exercise and so in one study
we looked at 12 weeks of interval
exercise training where the total time
commitment was only 10 minutes three
times a week and so within those
ten minute periods that was one minute
of very vigorous exercise with a warm-up
cooldown and so one group doing
10-minute time commitment with only one
minute of vigorous exercise another
group doing 55 zero minutes of
continuous exercise three times a week
so big differences in time commitment
and what we found was the improvement in
their cardio spiritual fitness the
improvement in measures of blood sugar
control insulin sensitivity we're very
similar despite these big differences in
time commitment and we think that
resonates with people or has some
application because the number one cited
barrier for why people are not more
active is time or a lack of it are we
suggesting that that's all that people
should do no absolutely not the the
public health guidelines are based on
very good science but when you are time
pressed the interval exercise can be a
very effective option and so part of our
approach is what we and others have
called the movement menu so there's
there's some more there's some
traditional choices or selections and
we'd like to expand that menu that
people can can select from and on those
days when you're particularly time
pressed or periods of your life when
you're very busy interval exercise can
be very effective and it might it be 20
seconds of vigorous stair climbing a few
times through the day or this notion of
exercise snacking - nonetheless be very
effective okay
so like as you said like within three my
I think you said like 12 weeks right
well it is about three months you can
basically get the same kind of physical
fitness as you get with normally like
150 minutes of exercise yeah exactly and
you know that's been our longest study
to date but definitely you can see these
changes very quickly as well and for
example in our studies on type 2
diabetics as little as six of these
interval training sessions over two
weeks was enough for us to see
improvements in their blood sugar
control and even mechanistically when we
look
that biopsies from their skeletal
muscles we could show an improvement in
glucose transport capacity so that's
obviously these proteins that are
responsible for bringing glucose into
the cell and obviously then lowering it
in your blood we could see these changes
very very quickly so you can have
changes quite rapidly and if you
continue to do this
these changes are maintained over time
so you mentioned that there is a in a
diabetics you have done these studies so
like and also heart patient are these
done studies done in controlled
environment are like anybody like do
they need it some doctors advise if
somebody wants to do it these are done
obviously in in in controlled
environments and so for example in our
studies on type 2 diabetics every
participant before they were enrolled
into the study they went through a
12-lead ECG exercise stress test and we
received physician clearance for them to
be enrolled in the study and some of
them were not cleared to participate in
this type of activity and obviously in
the cardiac rehab setting it's it's it's
quite similar so our advice to
individuals is twofold one at the
individual level
if you're considering interval exercise
training it makes sense to be to check
with your physician and be properly
screened because on an individual level
someone may have silent risk factors
that may not make them suitable for this
type of exercise but on a big picture
level people do not need to be afraid of
interval exercise training and really
you're just talking about scaling the
intensity properly for a given
individual but as I mentioned interval
training has been widely studied now and
shown to be effective in individuals
with metabolic syndrome heart disease
coronary artery disease diabetes older
individuals so again at the big picture
level it's been widely applied and
studied and shown to be effective but at
the individual level we definitely
recommend proper screening before you'd
start or change your exercise program
and the last point I would make
his interval training can range from
these all-out very vigorous activities
like the 1 minute workout to something
as simple as interval walking so just
picking up the or varying the pace of
what's otherwise low intensity walking
activity even something as simple as
interval walking has been shown to be
more effective at improving fitness and
blood sugar control than just continuous
steady state walking in obese older
individuals with type 2 diabetes and
that's that's good that you mentioned
about it because like I was thinking
about a-okay like intense exercise some
younger kids can do like a 20 thirties
forties but if you think about 50 60
people or 70s they want something like
more than what it they're doing like
regular walking they can also do the
brisk walking for about 20 seconds top
eight do it slow motion for another
minute or so again 20 seconds mix risk
walking so that will help them to
exactly it and that's been shown to be
effective so the analogy is if you're
only exercises walking around the block
at night after dinner pick up the pace
for a few light posts and then back off
and as simple as that sounds that's been
shown to be actually more effective than
just the continuous steady state walking
so our advice is just get out of your
comfort zone a little bit for a period
of time and then back off another
question regarding this walking like
high-intensity workout so is there any
guidelines like you need to do something
initially like preparation for this kind
of exercise like you can just go and do
it so you know and and so if someone is
just completely sedentary and they they
don't do any exercise at all the general
advice would be to start slow and build
from there and so for those individuals
even doing just some steady-state
walking to start would be recommended
and we also know that for lowering your
risk of cardiovascular disease and
diabetes and dying from all causes just
moving out of that lowest level of
fitness provides the most benefit so
doing anything is gonna be better than
nothing and probably provides the most
benefits for for you and and from there
you can start to you know scale it
appropriately also the type of exercise
plays a role here and so it's not only
about potential cardiovascular risk
especially if someone who's older may be
a little bit heavier they have joint
concerns and so there's certain types of
activities that are more suited to
interval exercise so cycling swimming
rowing these are non or less
weight-bearing activities and so the
relative stress on the joints is is
quite low and similar to continuous
forms of exercise now if you're doing
stair climbing or running or running
uphill the potential for the impact
forces on the joints and the potential
for injury is going to be higher and so
again this is where we really have to
say what type of interval training are
we talking about and it it it's a it's a
broad spectrum so there's certain types
that are appropriate for certain
individuals and certain types that are
probably not appropriate so consecutive
our doctor before you start doing and
it's something like this yes and this is
where you know if people are able to
even you know a session or two with a
good qualified or certified personal
trainer if if that's available to them
it can be it can be worth the time and
the investment but otherwise there's
there's a lot of resources online and
you know the reason I wrote my book was
to try and distill what's often complex
and conflicting science down into
hopefully what's an accessible read for
individuals and to provide some guidance
and in the in the book for example we
provide twelve different interval
training workouts all based on
scientific studies but they range from
what we call the beginner width which is
really just interval walking all the way
up to the 1 minute workout which would
be one of the most vigorous and intense
versions ok and like each organ has its
own internal clock they say and
like you mentioned about all the
Hartmann secretion insulin and all those
things is there any good time to do this
hit are like you can do it any time the
big answer is you can do it any time and
so I think the message for people is do
what works for you do what fits into
your schedule we've done some studies
for example looking at whether people
did interval training twice a day or
once every other day or if they did
interval training in the morning after
an overnight fast or if they did it
later in the day after eating or in the
morning with breakfast or not breakfast
and the big picture answer is all of
those can be effective there may be some
slight subtle differences but you know
if you exercise in the morning after an
overnight fast
maybe you burn a few more calories from
fat but in the big picture it doesn't
really matter especially if you're not a
morning person yeah yeah that's pretty
true like like my I go for exercise like
basically before lunch or after before
dinner but my wife's wants to eat
something before she goes for exercise
so I think it is individual thing so
whatever works for you you should do I
guess that's the message I guess yes it
is really the big picture message you
know if you're the elite athlete who
really cares about the enth degree of
performance and we can really dial it in
for you but for ninety nine percent of
the population it probably doesn't
matter and so it's more important to
just get it in and be consistent rather
than exactly when you do it so now going
back going to the biochemical part of it
like yeah I mentioned all these you
mentioned various types of exercise you
can do and all those things so some of
your work shows that this generates like
more mitochondria can you please explain
how does it have yeah so first of all
you know mitochondria are obviously
extremely important we mainly study
mitochondria in skeletal muscle which
obviously is very active during exercise
and we also know that individuals who
have a higher mighty Khan
content in their muscles that's
associated with a lower risk of
developing various chronic diseases
including things like type 2 diabetes
now whether those are directly causally
related or just associated there's some
debate but the bottom line is more
mitochondria is good whether you're an
athlete or just an average person who's
looking to maintain your health we know
that these mitochondria which are like
networks that run through the fiber you
can expand or increase the density of
these mitochondria in muscle and the the
molecular signaling pathways that cause
this are fairly well understood now and
fairly well articulated and in some of
our studies we've looked at and
demonstrated that these short bursts of
interval exercise can activate
mitochondrial biogenesis or this process
of creating new or additional
mitochondria very similar to traditional
exercise so we've literally shown at the
molecular level that the process of
creating more mitochondria can be
triggered in in different ways and so
the analogy we use is it's a bit like
you know a gas pedal and so as you the
traditional way is you step on the gas
pedal and that's going to lower the fuel
gauges slowly in your muscles and your
body responds to that drop in fuel over
time what it appears is you can step on
the gas pedal very hard drop the fuel
gauges relatively quickly even if it's
for a short period of time and the the
molecular energy sensors in the body
appear to respond in in a similar manner
and and so that's sort of a simple
analogy that people might understand for
for why we think these short bouts of
exercise can nonetheless be be effective
it comes down to these molecular fuel
gauges and muscle and what they sense
and that there is another molecule which
is known to involved in the energy
metabolism which is called creatine
kinase like it lets you use creatine to
boost their energy and all those things
so is that any work done on looking at
the creatine kinase enzyme there is you
know from from sprint training there you
can definitely develop your non aerobic
or anaerobic pathways and and so there's
some evidence that your ability to to
utilize phosphocreatine and work through
the creatine kinase pathway faster that
can be up regulated but there's not much
evidence to suggest that creates and
supplementation is is beneficial for
aerobic performance we know that creates
and supplementation is effective for
doing these shorter repeated bouts of
exercise but that doesn't necessarily
translate into more mitochondria for for
example okay and exercise is known to
affect the brain function which is well
known so how about your intense training
helps with the brain function yeah
that's a newer area of investigation and
so certainly we're collaborating with
some people who are brain experts here
at McMaster both on the the neurogenesis
side of things so literally can you know
can the can the structure and function
of the brain change and also on the
behavioral side so does this potentially
promote learning for example and so some
of my colleagues are interested in these
questions
manipulating the intensity the basically
the dose of exercise and what does that
mean and can if you make people more fit
does that mean indices of brain function
are enhanced so that's definitely a very
active area of research but some of my
colleagues for example have shown that
taking short activity bouts can actually
enhance outcomes on standardized testing
of students so literally taking a break
during your class and doing a little bit
of movement may actually enhance
learning there's some evidence for that
okay that is interesting to know and
getting back to like exercise means like
you need skeletal much
all those things like it helps you build
up mass a little bit so like I have seen
some of your work on this muscle fiber
recruitment can you please elaborate on
that
yeah so you know broadly speaking
there's two main types of muscle fibers
type one or slow-twitch fibers these are
fibers that we utilize or recruit all
the time for relatively low intensity
effort activities of daily living and
these type to these larger more powerful
fast-twitch muscle fibers and those are
the types of fibers in particular that
have been implicated or associated with
aging that they can sort of atrophy more
over over time definitely with interval
exercise training part of the benefit is
you recruits all of these muscle fibers
and there's some suggestions that that's
what makes interval exercise training
particularly beneficial is rather than
just having a population of fibers that
respond you recruit and and all of these
fibers adapt to the exercise and so
again right now we have some ongoing
studies through some collaborations
looking at fiber specific adaptations in
in mitochondria with this with this type
of training okay and people also talk
about stem cells like when you do these
exercises it helps you to get like
especially in the brain and all so is
there any work done on heat and any stem
cell III think there's some emerging
research you know look because one of
the big questions in physiology is how
you know okay I exercise my muscles work
my heart works hard my blood vessels
stretch and flex to allow the blood and
oxygen to move through so you can
appreciate okay it makes sense that
those particular organs or tissues or
cells would respond and adapt but how
does exercise make our skin more supple
or you know how does exercise enhance
brain health and so clearly this
suggests some sort of in tour or Ganesha
and there's been interest in mile Kines
which are
proteins released from muscle fibers
that may circulate to other tissues my
colleague Mark Turner Polsky has used
the term extra kind to describe these
proteins or compounds that might be
released specifically in response to
exercise and mark has a big interest in
these potential extra kinds and how they
might facilitate some of these
adaptations and other other organs and
and and cells and so again another area
of a very active research how does
exercise signal to these other areas of
the body and cause adaptation there and
one of the known functions like with
these kind of activities like
high-intensity workout is like vo2 max
so like just explained on that how it is
helpful for the German health so so vo2
max is what that means is the maximum
rate of oxygen use by the body and so
typically you measure B vo2 max much
like an exercise stress test you have
people do progressively higher workloads
on a bike and measure their oxygen
uptake usually through through a mask
vo2 Max is really important if you're an
endurance athlete you need a very high
vo2 max to be able to compete
successfully but it's also very
important for everyday individuals as
well because it's the best objective
marker of cardio spirit or fitness and
so people will hear this term cardio
health or Cartier Spirit or eat Fitness
and what that means is it's really just
vo2 max and we know that individuals who
have a higher cardio spirit or e fitness
have a lower risk of developing chronic
diseases and have a lower risk of dying
and so for example people who have
roughly a 10% higher cardio spirit or E
fitness on average their risk of dying
is about 13% lower their risk of
developing chronic diseases is about 15%
lower and that's a very strong and well
established relationship to the point
where a couple of years ago there was a
call from the American Heart Association
that courteous
spirit Ori Fitness should be a vital
sign that we measure just like body
temperature and blood pressure the
challenge of course is it's not
something that's easily measured in the
doctor's office but there are some
pretty good online calculators and so if
your listeners might want to get a
pretty good
index of their car to your spirit or
fitness I would encourage them to Google
world fitness level and there's a
calculator that they can plug in some
numbers their age their sex typical
activity levels their resting heart rate
and it'll give them a decent estimate of
their cardio spirit or a fitness and
that calculator is based on a trove of
good data that's been collected in in
Norway so it's not a perfect calculator
but it's a pretty good index and it can
at least allow them to track changes in
their fitness over time so are they
improving or decreasing over time but
cardio spirit or fitness vo2 max it's
important whether you're an athlete or
just an average individual and you also
mentioned that insulin sensitivity the
metabolism is better with these kind of
exercises can you please elaborate on
that yeah so generally speaking exercise
training of any way is is a or any type
is a way a mechanism to improve your
instantl and sensitivity probably
related in part to this enhanced ability
to transport glucose or blood sugar by
skeletal muscle definitely there's
evidence to show that interval training
can be a time effective way or time
efficient way to improve your your
insulin sensitivity you know this is
largely based on what I would call proof
of concept studies so relatively small
studies that that show these benefits
and so sometimes when I talk about
interval training I'll use the analogy
of it's a bit like the new drug on the
market so it's it's showing a lot of
efficacy in smaller phase trials early
investigations but we don't have the
robust evidence from you know level 4 or
grade-a evidence from large-scale
randomized controlled studies
looking at interval exercise training
versus the traditional approach on so
certainly the field is moving in this
manner and that's why for example we
don't see interval training generally
reflected in the public health
guidelines you know the American
guidelines were recently updated and
there was not a specific recommendation
to say you should do this much interval
training and that's going to be as good
as the traditional approach but
certainly one thing the American
guidelines did they removed what had
been a previous suggestion that exercise
has or physical activity had to be
accumulated in bouts of ten minutes at a
time now the guidelines suggest exercise
of any duration can be effective and I
think that's in part owing to some of
the interval training studies that have
shown these benefits with very very
small doses and certainly not anywhere
close to 10 minutes of continuous
activity at a time so I think that was a
positive change in the recent US
guidelines so like as you said like he
may not replace right now the
traditional whatever people are doing so
you do the regular thing plus add this
one minute thing in between so that will
help you and for those who don't have
time so always the complaint oh I don't
have time a you can't spare one minute
of time or ten minutes so you can do
that one minute exercise that is where
you think it is for the people is more
beneficial yeah I do and again I come
back this idea time is the number one
sighted barrier clearly it's an excuse
for a lot of people but some people lead
very busy time press lives the other
point I would make about interval
exercise is it's a type of activity you
can incorporate anywhere you know and so
we here stair climbing is good for us
but in our recent studies we were
looking at people who are doing these
stair climbing exercise snacks and so
what that involved was just 20 seconds
of vigorous stair climbing that's about
sixty stairs or about fleet three
flights if you're trying to picture what
that is and people did that three times
through the day so a 20 20 second bout
of vigorous stair climbing just three
times through the day with up to four
hours of time in between
even that was effective enough for us to
see a measurable change in their fitness
now with the Fitness improvement wasn't
as good as what we've seen with our
other more involved interval training
studies so again we're not suggesting a
few exercise snacks is going to provide
all of the benefits but it at least can
be effective and so on those days when
you're particularly time pressed just
taking the stairs at work as you come
into your office again at lunch you're
on a break and before you go home it can
still be a good preventative maintenance
dose of exercise you know another
analogy is or another example is what I
call hotel room workouts so on those
days when you're traveling you don't
have access to your regular facilities
you can do some sort of body weight
intervals in your room think of things
like burpees push-ups running in place
jumping jacks air squats these types of
exercise that don't require specialized
equipment
it doesn't require any large particular
space it just gets your heart rate up
that can be very effective application
of interval training principles to at
least maintain and otherwise give your
fitness a boost so now that you've not
picked up it is interesting that like
some of us like thinking that oh it's
too cold to go out during winter so you
better sit at home or if you have stairs
go up and down on the stairs
and get your workout down at least few
times a day that will help you yeah and
part of it is it's a mind shift a little
bit you know a lot of people think
exercise is this thing that we do at a
gym after we change into our spandex you
know if you like to do that fantastic
keep doing it but it's not the only way
it's about physical activity and you
know we've done such a good job of
engineering physical activity out of our
lives so we have to look for ways to
incorporate it back in and what we're
reminding people is you don't need a gym
you don't need specialized equipment you
don't even need much time in order to to
get these bouts of physical activity in
and even very short boats can
nonetheless be effective for your health
so finally let's
talk about your book so that you can
find your book and if at all somebody
wants to contact you to learn more about
interval exercise or to do some research
in your lab so what is the best way to
go about it sure so the book is called
the one minute workout I was published
by penguin Random House you can get it
online it's available as an audiobook as
well so you can pretty much find it
anywhere but certainly on Amazon and all
of the major booksellers my website is
Martin Gabala comm and so people could
find information on our research they
could find other podcasts like this that
that I've done on various topics and
they can see some of the media reports
on our on our research as well and they
can contact me through that site as well
I'm not particularly active on social
media but I tweet occasionally at Gabala
M so people can also follow me there or
tweet at me and I'd be happy to answer
any questions so thank you very much dr.
de bellas I really appreciate your help
in educating the people about this high
internal exercise so look forward to
seeing your good work in the near future
thank you so much I appreciate the
opportunity beyond and share some of
this with your listeners thank you thank
you